congratulations uh minati i'm saying it
correctly
i was blown away by this film
and i loved how much it surprised me i
i was truly surprised by so many
elements of the movie and
really had felt invested in this family
in in an amazing way the performances
are fantastic
um and i
loved that i didn't feel like i was
being
manipulated as someone as an audience
member
uh sometimes there are films that are
telling me what to think
or trying to show me what i'm supposed
to think
and this is a movie that really
is about a family yeah and
a family that's in very strong it's an
immigrant family
undergoing yeah this these different
trials and tribulations but
nothing felt hackneyed nothing felt like
oh i've seen this before
it was truly original i appreciate that
yeah um
yeah you know that was that wasn't like
explicitly our intention or goal but
those are things that i think like
were natural thoughts and byproducts of
what we're trying to make which was like
something honest to you know
an experience that you know isaac our
director and i
share you know isaac uh that that
immigrant experience especially the
korean american one
is is you know it's so wide and vast
there's so many variations of it but
like where we wanted to focus
it all um was just the family
and this particular specific family and
so we did
you know we kind of just held the truth
of that family and
i'm so happy to know that like everyone
was able to access it people were able
to access it and like
connect at levels of like being a father
or
a mother or a family and um
it's honestly it's been kind of strange
because
you know when you're making the film
you're very aware of how
the world and namely america and the
internet
wants to talk about things and so we're
very conscious we you can't help but be
conscious of those things and so for us
we were just trying to get to the human
experience of these characters
and um how how one of the things
one of the mechanisms by which we try to
do that was just like
let's not explain ourselves yeah like
why like people can't see
like you don't need to explain ourselves
like
especially nowadays like if you want to
be
curious about a culture or something go
look it up or like go deeper into it or
we'll hold it for you and you can
you can access this but we didn't want
to explain ourselves
and what was odd about it coming out and
having
it come out to the world is one you have
no control on how it's perceived
and and that's a lesson that i've
learned um and two
it was hard to navigate not explaining
ourselves yeah
because like every question was like can
you explain what this is and it's like
you know what this is it's it's family
it's
it's like life well also people are
looking for there's a hiss
you know your nomination is historic and
that probably can feel like have a
double edge to it which is totally
you know um people want to say oh
this is the first actor from
this ethnic group and you want to say
well that that's
that's tricky because you know pardon my
french is just a
great performance that you give thanks
and it really just a beautiful ex
portrait of a family well we have a clip
here from minari i guess i can lay a
little
groundwork your character has made
this uh big leap of faith and big choice
to to go and realize his dream of
being a farmer and something that's a
little
it's a big ask of the rest of the family
and one of the first things you need to
do is find
water yeah and so uh here's a scene and
by the way the boy in this film so great
is
so terrific yeah i think just just a
classic iconic
performance by a child that people are
going to talk about for a long time but
let's take a look at this scene from
inari
where will the water go
high place or low place low place
crochet okay chrome low place all this
stuff
there crochet
there okay
there why because trees like water
and this film was made what two years
ago would you say we shot this film
the road to it was crazy uh 20
2018 end of 2018 i read the script
and then we went into production june
the next year of 2019
and then we premiered at sundance
january of 2020.
because that boy is now six feet six
inches yeah he's he's in college
in college he's at fordham for all the
money he's at fordham he comes down for
allah
yo
[Laughter]
we missed his you know we miss his best
years now he's just